que ce que les gens ils veulent
aujourd'hui c'était partage la
gentillesse et de la simplicité c'est à
dire ils ont nourrir en affrontant mais
qui présente une ducati chiron certains
ce qu'ils veulent c'est que c'est une
met au même niveau clocks qu'on est tous
au même niveau sans talent tv ou te
donne un rôle je lis la presse
automobile du peuple
[Musique]
cette voiture je suis particulièrement
content après des voitures août et plus
contents d'autres tu vas et ça ça fait
partie des voitures où je suis plus
content que d'autres restent et saab
était quand même c'est un achèvement
pour moi tu as
vu le sait la voiture qui m'a fait
connaître entre guillemets
c'est symbolique en fait
je suis fier comme un coq de chez
empreinte expliqué c'est exactement ce
que je vais expliquer aux frérot qui
vont regarder la vidéo c'est qu'avec le
paka beteta les petites lames en carbone
là qui sont pas d'origine c'est à la
grosse lame dessous du par chevron
carbone qui est pas d'origine tu as le
rs 6 r du coup quelle appellation de la
voiture préparée par ab t ta légendes
modifiées le pare-chocs modifier le
diffuseur l'intérieur le 1 sur 5 parce
que c'est une série limitée à 5 voitures
dans le monde les gens quand tu
débarques la voiture même s'ils savent à
peu près là qu'elle sait c'est vraiment
le moment où
c'est un moment d'émotion pour les amis
la famille j'espère vous allez bien on
se retrouve aujourd'hui pour une
aberrante vidéo va commencer par la lame
donc là frérot comme tu peux le
constater là on a une lame et une plaque
donc il ya déjà ma plaque dessus
[Musique]
brut maintenant je l'emmenais à monaco
pour vous puissiez voir un peu la
journée comment ça va se passer et du
coup la première fois que je sors la
voiture on va la garder place du casino
et on va aller à la rencontre un peu des
gens qui se trouve là bas
[Musique]
la première photo que m'accorde et je me
suis dit mais qu'est ce qui s'passe tu
sais pourquoi il demande une photo qui
suit il ya des gens qui me qui me
suivent entre guillemets ça fait
longtemps que je suis là depuis ce
depuis 8 ans 9 ans sur ces essais qui
m'ont jamais crime 3 bat pour eux trois
c1 c'est un événement est pour moi aussi
parce que pour moi c'est un honneur de
croiser quelqu'un qui me suit depuis
sept huit neuf ans des fois tu vois
[Musique]
ça va
m
[Musique]
ouais ça va moi je t'ai eue dans le cas
il ya une semaine
m et je savais que c 'est la gr
new phantom héros
il n'y a pas de distance entre les
moissac stc ce rapport humain et c'est
aussi pour ça que je fais ça c'est pour
avoir du lien avec les gens extérieurs
mais je suis en train de mettre en place
des des projets pour faire kiffer les
gens et partager avec eux est réellement
c'est à dire
de faire des projets concrets ou
reviennent et touche tu ailles qui fit
38 this entre la chose physiquement pas
que virtuellement on veut encore plus
rendre accessible tu vois les voitures
parce que c'était encore toutes
distances entre les gens et les voitures
lavéra s'avère totalement aberrant
c'est ça tous les jours c'est à tous les
gens mais savez ça fait kiffer ça fait
partie du concept voit donc c'est
toujours un plaisir ouais ça passe du
casino à monaco
je viens tous les jours tiré du tuning
et j'ai mes voitures qui sont garés pas
très loin donc des cas un changement de
voiture en fait c'est ici que ça se
passe et il ya des gens qu'ils savent
donc il ya souvent un peu de
deux personnes qui sont là dans la tente
ça fait plaisir de les rencontrer à
chaque fois et ce qui est bien avec
voitures et le public passion comme ça
c'est que c'est un public de plusieurs
raisons d'adopter nationalité ajoute des
couleurs de peau de toutes les religions
tous les stades du sociologue voiture
c'est vraiment un public du lac et à
bardos du mobilier moi ma vie j'essaye
de la ville mais le moins possible c'est
vraiment rester sur les voitures purgera
restait sur
mais moi ça lui aujourd'hui j'ai fait ci
balamage bien générer 6-6 s'appelle
cufré roman qu'il faut pour sa voiture
et après je vois pas pourquoi moi je
leur ai exposé ma vie sachant que je ne
sais pas
m
[Musique]
je veux dire aux jeunes c'est de croire
en leur potentiel de croire en eux de
croire en leurs rêves et de quand même
se donner les moyens d'y arriver mais
sans se laisser ralentir par les autres
parce que les autres essaieront toujours
notre inventaire